This video is going to be about the proof
of Bell's theorem, but I made another video
explaining the significance of Bell's theorem
and I think it would really helpful to watch
that first -- So if you haven't watched that
video then you can click this link to be taken
to it.
So hopefully Nobody Who Hasn't Watched The
Other Video is here.
Remember that what we want to prove today
is Bell's theorem that entangled particles
communicate to each other faster than light.
Before I start on the details of the proof,
I'll explain the main idea.
Last video I told you guys about something
called Spin, and some weird experimental facts
about it.
I won't show you how, but it is possible to
explain Spin in the frame work of Quantum
Mechanics.
However, say we didn't believe anything could
go faster than light.
Then, because of EPR, quantum mechanics couldn't
be true.
Therefore, we'd have to look for an alternative
theory where nothing ever acted faster than
light.
We'll call all the theories in this category
'local theories'.
What this proof is going to show is that,
no matter how cleverly we try, we could never
come up with a local theory that can explain
spin.
We'll do that by a proof by contradiction.
In other worlds we start by believing it is
possible and see what happens.
There's one particular experiment with spin
that we'll try explain.
Let's say I have some source of electrons
with entangled spins.
This means that if A and B are a pair, if
I choose to measure them both in the same
axis, one will be up and the other down.
Now, A and B are sent off to two machines
very far from each other, which we will call
Alice and Bob.
Alice and Bob can each measure the spin of
their electron in three different axes.
These are the 3 axes and we choose them so
that they are 120 degrees apart from each
other.
When A arrives at Alice, Alice randomly chooses
an axes to measure A's spin in, and Bob does
the same thing with B.
But they do it independently from each other,
so Alice could measure spin around 2 and Bob
around 3 for example.
If the machines measure their electron to
be spin up then they flash red, or if it's
spin down they flash white.
Someone notes if they're the same colour or
not.
This experiment is repeated many times.
The question is, what fraction of the time
will their colours be different?
The answer is actually half, and if you're
willing to take my word for that then you
can skip this part and move to the most interesting
part of the proof.
If not, then stick around and we'll figure
out why that's the case, using the rules of
spin from last time.
Ok, I'm assuming you've decided to stay.
Let's say Alice measured around axis 1, and
happened to get spin down.
Let's see how likely Bob is to measure spin
down as well.
The reason I can just pick a particular case
like this is because all the other cases will
work out in the same way, to the same result.
Well, one 1/3 of the time, Bob will choose
axis 1 as well, so since A and B are entangled,
Bob's particle will definitely have spin up
in that direction so the colours don't match.
What about if Bob measured around axis 2?
Because A is down in the first axis, B must
be spin up in the first axis, so we just have
to figure out, how much of this spin is pointing
in the 2nd direction.
Actually as you can see, this vector is partly
pointing in the negative direction of axis
2.
What does this mean?
It means that if you measure the spin in axis
2, it is either going to be up or down, but
more likely down.
So in this case A and B are more likely than
not going to have the same sp in and the colours
are more likely to be the same.
What about axis 3?
This is a really similar story to 2.
As you can see, this vector is pointing in
the negative direction of axis 3, so most
of the time B will be down if it is measured
in axis 3, so again they A and B will most
likely have the same colour.
let's review those 3 cases again:
If Bob is on axis 1, Alice and Bob definitely
won't have the same colour.
If Bob is on axis 2 or 3 though, more often
than not Alice and Bob will have the same
colour.
It works out so that overall there's an exactly
50% chance that Alice and Bob have the same
colour and 50% chance they don't.
Ok, so now, we're going to see if a local
theory could explain this result.
Firstly let's think about what happens when
Alice and Bob happen to pick the same axis.
A and B have to be opposite spins.
We know that if nothing goes faster than light,
the only way this is can happen is if the
particles decided there spins while they were
in contact.
We don't know how they decide who gets which
spin but the awesome thing about this argument
is that it doesn't matter.
All that matters is that each particle A and
B have decided what there spins are in each
of the 3 directions before hand.
There are 8 possibilities:
This one is that A is spin up in axis 1 and
3 but spin down in axis 2.
Then of course B is the opposite.
It would take a while if we had to go through
every single possibility, but luckily for
me we don't.
We'll just look at the case were A is spin
up in axis 1 and 3 and spin down in 2 and
the case where A is spin up in every axis.
Why can we get away with this?
Because we can get the other cases either
by swapping which particle we call A and B,
which doesn't matter, or swapping the names
of the axes, which also doesn't matter.
Convince yourself that that's true.
Ok, so let's consider the case that A is all
spin up.
If so what's the chance that Alice and Bob
will have the same colour?
No matter which axes get picked A is always
up, and B is down, so they're always different
spins whenever they adopt this plan.
What about the other plan?
This is A's spins in each axis and underneath
is B's.
Alice and Bob randomly pick an axes, and there
are a few possibilities for what happens:
Alice could pick 1 then Bob could pick 1 as
well, so they are different colours
Or he could pick 2 which means that they'd
have the same colour etc, and we just go through
and tally up all 9 possibilities and find
that 5 out of the nine times they are different
colours.
So that means that whether or not A and B
picked a plan like this or like the previous
type, they will always be more likely to have
the same colour.
But as we already know, this isn't the right
result
So you see, local theories just don't have
the right tools to explain spin.
I think that's because spin is a crazy phenomena
that is nothing like the classical properties
of matter that we're used to.
On the hand any local theory is quite classical
because it assumes particles can't effect
each other instantly over distances which
really limits how weird it can be and in this
case, its just too classical to explain something
like spin.
So that's Bell's theorem.
I promised to cover a couple of topics last
time so I'll work on that, but don't expect
them too soon.
On that optimistic note, see you next time.